[Music]
we're all painfully aware that Disney
and Pixar are the same thing Disney
still feels the need to jerk itself off
for 40 seconds before the movie starts
movie steals the expositional
documentary inside the actual movie
motif from Citizen Kane science doesn't
make discoveries people do and also
these two assholes and whoever's filming
this newsreel and supposed to the normal
everyday paddy wagon which was somehow
lesser capacity and had no chance in
hell of telling us what era this movie
is set in these look more like dog
torture devices than contraptions can
see poor canine comfort it sounds like
Pixar's turn-of-the-century idiom
generator just malfunction I mean holy
mackerel how many cockeyed phrases are
these bones gonna throw at me why
because this guy doesn't know how to use
a compass or this guy doesn't know how
bones work or possibly because it's
convenient to the plot Karl conveniently
overhears Ellie say this just as he
walks past the dilapidated house
prompting him to find out who said it if
Ellie just saw the same screening of
Monza's documentary how was she able to
find this abandoned house and rig it up
to play Explorer before Karl had enough
time to walk past it and catch her in
the middle of her narrative nope he
won't be able to for 60 years Karl's
balloon that Ellie now inexplicably
possesses still has enough helium in it
to lift a large stick just high enough
into the air to go into Karl's room and
buy some kind of dog talking level
witchcraft is able to change directions
as soon as it reaches Carl's bedroom
window behind every great man is a woman
pointing and yelling at him to make
uncapable promises movie completely
blows past Ellie dropping her tomboy
persona and how this couple managed to
stay in love during their awkward
highschool years in college years based
on their mutual respect of Charles Muntz
this is a prime example of when
sentimental value goes totally wrong
instead of buying a house they can
actually live in Carl and Ellie decide
to buy the condemned house they met in
and spend the first few years of their
lives basically rebuilding the entire
think I can't even imagine what the
inspection for this was like and this
house has been abandoned for well over a
decade that's not a fun renovation
project that's a tennis Shack Elian Carl
do manual labor in their wedding clothes
movie takes place in an alternate
universe where super helium exists but
adoption apparently doesn't weren't
quite ready to explain miscarriages to
your children well now you have to how
much change could they possibly have in
that jug fifteen dollars and if they
fill it up maybe thirty they'll have
enough money to check out a documentary
about Paradise Falls but will definitely
be a few thousand dollars short of
actually paying for a trip also when we
actually go to Paradise Falls later in
the film we see that it's still
completely remote and uninhabited how do
they plan on actually getting there are
they saving up for their own Zeppelin
also Paradise Falls is based on a real
place in Venezuela called can Diamond a
tional park and if we make believe
that's the actual Paradise Falls I bet
it would be challenging for them to
claim residence in a Venezuelan National
Park goddamn they did a fantastic job
restoring that probably 70 year old
house did they reinforce it with steel
beams and then suddenly and without any
warning Pixar sends you into a montage
that is both full of sadness and joy and
more sadness without a word of dialogue
spoken it's like one of those great
Pixar shorts that precede all the
full-length features and I think I just
cried a little it's downright incredible
and we're removing five sins for its
brilliance I believe I made my position
to your boss quite clear you poured
fruit juice at his gas tank I find this
unlikely this assumes the boss drives a
car that doesn't have one of those
spring-loaded gas doors that you'd have
to actually break into the car to open
or the boss just leaves his car unlocked
all day at a construction site also this
old man who uses a cane somehow managed
to get to the car without being seen
carrying a funnel and some prune juice
and how did they even figure out it was
prune juice unless they saw him and let
him do it Carl told them Lord they ran
it to a lab and why didn't the boss
press charges House John Ratzenberger is
acting like this is new information even
though he said earlier also I have a
hard time believing whatever faceless
corporation is in charge of this project
doesn't just pay off whoever and abuse a
little eminent domain to steal Carl's
house away from it Russell's persistence
leads me to believe he thinks Carl is
the only old person in this town earlier
we told the Carl juice at his gas tank
and that didn't seem to create any
issues but after Carl assaults this
worker he's forced to sell his house and
move into an old folks home I understand
that assault is a worse crime than
damage of personal property but the
latter is still a crime and that
seemingly went completely unpunished
these assholes still wear their
sunglasses in court
no so-called judge would allow so was
crowned sentenced by the court to live
in a retirement community is it a
retirement village / prison man karl was
a terrible balloon salesman also how did
he have the time to blow up all these
balloons and keep them hidden before the
Shady Oaks folks showed up and we really
expected to believe that Karl isn't
physically fit enough to walk down the
stairs in his own house but can climb
all over the roof to tie those balloons
and set up a steering mechanism there's
no amount of loons this movie could
animate that would convince me balloons
could rip a house from its foundation
and all this connected utilities also
Carl doesn't disconnect the electricity
in water before his grand escape also
also if these balloons could rip up a
house off its foundation and let it fly
away then how the actual was Karl able
to keep them concealed behind his house
until this point are the impossibly
giant tarps that he has for some reason
as dense as neutron stars also times
three way to use an increasingly scarce
resource to fly your house irresponsibly
you jackass even though karl has yet to
engage his steering apparatus the house
manages to avoid all the tall buildings
during its ascent Karl's balloon house
is a dick to analog television Oh ain't
that nice the airplane billboard
features South America prominently in
this North American town you know
because of the story and all these
shower curtains make clever sales and
imply that Karl always possess the
knowledge how to fly a house without at
least one practice track also numerous
military and police would have been
called when they heard the reports of a
flying house using balloons but
fortunately for Karl this took place
during Taco Tuesday and no one called to
care oh really then where were you when
this happened not only do I not see any
wilderness explorers under Karl's porch
but I also can't see a way to get under
the porch in the first place you'd think
but karl has done zero steering since he
got in the air and it's totally
absolutely amazing he hasn't checked to
see if he needs to dodge aircraft or
tall buildings but if you train these
balloons well they know where to go Wow
good thing
Russell is impossible here so you could
warn Karl about the clouds not Karl
would have just been sleeping in his
chair when this storm came in and movie
over at least we would have had the
montage Karl's house doesn't completely
break apart nor do enough of the
balloons pop in the storm causing them
to fall out of the sky
[Music]
so I piloted this house all the way to
South America anyway was Karl asleep for
several days or does the movie want me
to believe they were a storm and a nap
away from Venezuela the momentum of this
giant house guided by balloons and being
dragged by an elderly person and a child
stops right at the edge of the cliff
just like all the airplanes tanks fast
and furious isn't starship
enterprise's we've ever seen you think
that a 50-ton kite wouldn't allow a kid
and an old man to maintain their
position but you'd be wrong not only do
they drop out of the sky right on top of
the place where Carl and Ellie always
wanted to go but they just so happen to
be adjacent to the Vista that's painted
above their fireplace
the same angle and everything talk about
crotchety carl accidentally flies his
house hundreds of miles and ends up just
a few short miles of where he wants to
be and he's still pissed he should
probably just settle and plop his house
right here and begin starving to death
at least they could look at the
waterfall while they died after all we
weighed down how what convenient physics
did they get down here in the last scene
they were walking along a cliff where
there were no trees but now it looks
like they're walking through the thick
jungle at the bottom of the cliffs did
they cut the scene where Russell and
Carl decided to take the physically
impossible route yeah so because there
aren't Tigers per se let's just stop in
the middle of the South American jungle
because no Tigers equals no other kinds
of animals that can kill you snipe even
though Russell still has his zoology
badge he still thinks this pterodactyl
size footprint was left behind by us
night oh I guess it can be forgiven that
Russell as a kid doesn't know what a
snipe looks like but I'm kind of curious
as to why he didn't research what Snipes
look like considering that he knew that
tiger fact about South America and looks
to be a dutiful wilderness explorer I
mean he should have known they don't
exist after the first day also why does
this kid even think the snipe came with
them on this journey in the first place
wasn't Russell under and inside the
house during this trip to South America
I'm fine with this misidentified snipe
for humor and story purposes just not
logic purposes Kevin a made-up animal
that is indigenous to South America has
a keen understanding of the English
language yeah that's totally gross but
then Carl picks it up completely dry
within 10 seconds of this happening oh
hey now they're back up on top of the
cliff you'd think since they have access
to some kind of wormhole they just use
it to magically go to the other side of
the cliff instead of just bouncing from
the top to the bottom but here we are
either Russell's pack is exclusively
filled with chocolate bars or he has
some sort of infinite chocolate bar that
came from the same factory where they
made Mary Poppins bag
Koller he is a good and smart master and
he made me this collar so that I may
talk squirrel
well is adorable and hilarious removing
us in jingle I use that course Doug's
collars program with Spanish a southern
accent and Japanese you know the three
main languages have you seen a bird I
want to find one and I've been honest
I'm a great tracker so does this collar
give these dogs a basic level of human
intelligence - or is this maybe
suggesting that dogs have the capacity
to think just like we do but are unable
to express themselves because they don't
have a few in vocal cords also if I put
this collar on a cow or a chicken would
they be able to speak in the same way
whether that mean that all animals are
secretly just as intelligent as we are
but are unable to express themselves I
just became a vegan Charles Muntz was
able to invent talking dog collars in
video chat using technology from the
1940s where the fuck is this camera
located I just saw Doug a few minutes
ago but I don't remember seeing a camera
on top of his head which is what this
current shot would suggest a dog that's
lived in jungle isolation with his other
dog pals and one other human for his
entire life is aware that mailman exists
the house and the hose that connects
them to it aren't constantly getting
caught in tree branches and this
wouldn't even be a sin if they just
stayed on top of the cliff where there
are no trees but instead they keep
reappearing in this dense jungle they
shouldn't have access to
yep I'm gonna send the old pastime of a
cartoon character and possibly
transporting ahead of the other
characters it's what we do unfortunately
whoever gave Russell the tent building
patch that I'm sure he has will
hopefully be disbarred from the
wilderness explorer community there must
be something in the South American air
that allowed Russell's face to heal so
quickly
Carl's surprised that Russell says this
like it was something he and Elia made
up on their own and not something that
people have said for decades
[Music]
birds calling babies how do you know
that just because your dog doesn't mean
you speak fluent bird and he'll earlier
you said you didn't even know what a
bird looked like so I do ride your bird
understanding abilities you saw this
bird on this little videophone
thingamajig right who cares about what
he said months has been able to maintain
a dog army for the past 70 years or so
with presumably very little food and no
female dogs
Carles once yes if he's actually Charles
months that would mean that he's at
least 15 to 20 years older than Karl I
imagine Karl's in his late 70s which
would put Charles well into his 90s
which isn't impossible but I imagine it
would be hard to maintain your health
with just a bunch of dogs a finite
amount of food and no doctors I mean
he's never even had a prostate exam
months found a cave large enough to fit
his blimp what do they tell the dogs
they need to have operations when they
have to wear this count is it still the
cone of shame why not have a crate of
shame if he means FDR time-wise that
would make sense button having trouble
visualizing him on safari with the
president who was famously in a
wheelchair if not him and the only other
famous roosevelt would be theodore
roosevelt given theos interest in
big-game hunting it makes sense that he
would be referring to him but given that
he died in 1919 when months was either
not born or a small child that really
looks up the timeline the dog how does
he do anything either that's a 70 year
old frozen hot dog or he's making his
own hot dogs out of the local squirrels
there's also the dog army Russell's been
eating chocolate for two days and
somehow refrains from inhaling this hot
dog before this asshole has enough time
to take it off his plate more often I
get thieves come to steal what's
rightfully mine you do you mean there
are actual people out there making trips
to remote parts of South America to
steal you I've spent a lifetime tracking
it and Carl and Russell ran into it
within minutes of arriving at Paradise
Falls but it ran off it's gone now
Carl lies two months for Kevin even
though he's made it clear several times
that he doesn't care for the bird and he
knows months won't kill him because in
order to be vindicated he has to return
with the bird a lot Carl should know
that if he's just honest about the Kevin
months won't harm him or Russell if
anything he's just putting Russell on
himself in serious danger also human
children are more important than birds
why am i forced to explain this to Pixar
none of you have even had dinner yet the
old man in the outer shape child are
able to outrun a pack of dogs the house
survives this Doug uses his super
strength to push these boulders down to
block the pack of dogs now Russell
survives this dog helm screen so they
decided to get Kevin back to her home
but they decided to lug the house with
them but why couldn't you just tie this
thing somewhere then you wouldn't have
to haul it back either because the
squirrel gets dead all the dogs have an
extreme hatred for squirrels yet we
haven't seen a single squirrel since
we've been in Paradise Falls at least
not since months got the hot dog machine
up and running not only of the balloons
stayed inflated for two to three days
now but they continued to not get popped
by branches haha funny joke but this
jungle has been anything but wild since
they got here they ran into one rare
bird and a bunch of trained dogs not in
their natural habitat and nothing else
even with all their treacherous detours
they still made it to the falls side of
the cliff just as the balloons ran out
of lift on some of these pictures Carl
flips through an Ellie scrapbook I can
honestly say where is camera yep telling
me they set up a delay on a camera and
got these candid shots or did they have
a photographer constantly following them
around if they trim the professional
photographer budget they probably could
have eked out a trip to Paradise Falls
upon further examination of Ellie's
chair I deem it unsuitable an old man
who needs a machine to go down the
stairs is able to throw all his
furniture out the front door Doug the
dog knows how to knock under your porch
is there some sort of magical alcove
under Carl's porch that allows dogs and
children to hide down there and then
move onto the porch while the house is
in the air Russell has Superman flight
powers with a leaf blower where he's
able to will himself forward even though
the leaf blower only blows at one speed
also how does he keep from continuing to
float upward yeah because you totally
figured out that he found a way to make
his house fly again even though he's
been hauling it around for the last
couple days Carl slings a hose and gets
the sprayer to grab on to the cargo door
on the first try
then he zip lines down at like it's
second nature we get past these dogs how
do they not smell your prune and denture
cream scent
Oh what were the other dog the dogs can
cook a gourmet meal and tie a human boy
to a chair but still need a chew toy to
fire a gun on a biplane okay I've been
pretty forgiving of Carl's super old
person abilities but I'm gonna have to
draw the line at climbing an upside-down
ladder and almost falling off but
catching himself I
movie continues it's needless assault on
squirrels also the dogs never get picked
up after this battle is over so I can
only assume they live the rest of their
lives starving in the Venezuelan jungle
I don't know too much about the
originals but I would imagine having a
house on the back would screw with the
balance and create an issue also it
looks like Carl the normal old man is
able to stop the house from sliding off
the back of it I put more faith in the
house ripping Carl's arms off before I
believe any of this I'm seeing right now
that guy falling to his death because
showing him died any other way it would
be too gruesome for kids movie cliche
nice transition but allow me to be a
dick for a moment because that means
they would have had to be in the exact
same position and do the exact same
things twice for this to be possible
yep I'm a dick you know yeah he clearly
doesn't need a cane did you see all the
people in the last scene will graduate
to senior explorers why do all these
kids get to graduate the senior explorer
they don't have all the badges man
Russell's mom was super okay with her
son being gone for three or four days
when continuing to let Russell see the
man the courts say is a menace to
society and is responsible for her kid
being gone in the first place I wonder
how much trouble Carl will get in with
the FAA for perking an unlicensed 60
year old airship above an ice cream
store you mean to tell me the house
landed ripe gah forget these end credits
are some more where is camera nonsense
[Music]
[Applause]
humility before nature it's being
displayed here on staggers believe me
just wait till they get a look at you
will they get a load of me
what kind of dining set defines me as a
person
all wings report in bread since Danny
beretta